we're on problem 17 and it asks us which
expression shows the complete
factorization of 12 x squared minus 147
let's see first of all is it can we
factor out 147 is a strange-looking
number let's see if we can factor out
something see it's definitely not
divisible by 12 because 12 goes into 144
sees is divisible by 3 1 plus 4 is 5 5
plus 7 is 12 and 12 is divisible by 3
and I don't know if you've seen that
before you just add up the digits and if
the digits if that is divisible by 3
then the number is divisible by 3 so 147
is divisible by 3 let's see what it is
147 I think I have a well let's work it
out it's 4 4 times 3 is 12 27 it's 49 so
we can factor 3 out of this so then it
becomes 3 times what's 12 divided by 3 4
x squared minus 147 divided by 3 we just
figured out was 49 and now this once
again has the property of it looks you
know just looks just like a squared
minus B squared where a would be 2x and
B would be 9 right so now we can factor
that more and I'll just switch colors
arbitrarily that becomes 3 times a plus
B so that would be 2x plus 7 times a
minus B 2x minus 7 and that is choice D
and choice D they wrote the 2x minus 7
first but it's the same difference so
it's choice D problem 18 let me see if I
can get problem 18 going problem 18 now
I don't need it well maybe I should cut
and paste it why not so I copied it and
then let me paste it here that's the
problem I'll rewrite it cuz I don't know
if that's big enough for you to see so
it says X plus 3 over X plus 5 plus 6
over x squared plus 3x minus 10 so when
you add fractions whether you're doing
it
with algebraic fractions or regular
fractions you have to find a common
denominator and let's see we have to
find the least common multiple of the
denominators here but I have a suspicion
that this X plus 5 goes into this let's
see if I can factor this what two
numbers when I multiply them equal minus
10 and when I add them equal plus 3
let's see well 5 5 times what is minus
10 it's 5 times minus 2 and 5 plus minus
2 is 3 so that works X minus 2 all right
so this is actually our least common
multiple this expression right here so
let me write it that way so that is
equal to I'm just going to rewrite this
as X plus 5 over X minus 2 now if X plus
3 over X plus 5 if we were to multiply
both of those times X minus 2 to get
something on in this form this X plus 3
over X plus 5 is the same thing as X
plus 3 times X minus 2 over X plus 5
times X minus 2 right you could just
cancel this out right here and you'd get
back to that right and now we're adding
that we're adding this term to this term
6 over this well this is the same thing
as this so that's just plus 6 and now we
just get into simplification mode so x
times X is x squared x times minus 2 is
minus 2 X 3 times X is plus 3 X 3 times
minus 2 is minus 6 so that's this term
right here got us that and then we have
the plus 6 and then all of that is over
this stuff and I look at the choices it
seems like they have it in this form so
I'll just write it in that form x
squared plus 3x minus 10 and let's see
this the minus 6 and the plus 6 cancels
out and we're left with minus 2x plus 3x
so that's x squared minus 2 plus 3 plus
X over x squared plus 3x minus 10 and
that is choice a
choice a next problem I'm almost out of
space
I'll draw a line here just so you don't
get distracted what does a simplified
form of and they write 3a squared B to
the 3rd C to the minus 2 all of that
over interesting a to the minus 1 B
squared C and all of that is to the
third power so let's get sin
simplification mode so this bottom part
we can Reese implement its a to the
negative 1 B squared C to the third
power that's each of these items to the
third power so a to the minus 1 to the
third power you can multiply the
exponents so that becomes a to the minus
3 I just took the negative 1 times a 3 B
squared to the third power that's B to
the 2 times 3 that's B to the sixth
power
and then finally C well let's just see
to the first to the third process C the
third and now we can just say well this
is the same thing let me switch colors
this color is getting mundane this is
equal to 3 times a to the 2 we're
dividing by my a to the negative 3rd so
it's 2 minus minus 3 right let me write
that just so you understand what 2 minus
minus 3 power that's where I got the 2
that's where I got the minus 3 and I
subtracted because I'm dividing times B
to the 3 minus 6 times C to the minus 2
minus 3 all right once again I'm only
see if we were multiplying these two I
would add the exponents but anyway let's
simplify this this equals 3 a 2 minus
minus so that's plus 3 a to the fifth B
to the minus 3 C to the minus 5 C to the
minus 5 and this is the same thing
this is the same thing as three a to the
fifth B to the minus three is the same
thing as one over B to the third so over
B to the third and is the same thing as
one over C to the fifth C to the fifth
and that is choice a choice a next
problem
next problem well we already finished
that page all right I can let me copy
and paste what they wrote C
let me put at the top of this right
there and paste it okay that's what
they're asking and I'll write it they 20
X to the minus fourth over 27 y squared
divided by this fraction so first of all
when you divide by a fraction that's the
same thing as multiplying by the inverse
right so let's do that I just know I
want to get rid of this pesky looking
Division sign so let's rewrite this is
20 X to the minus fourth over 27 y
squared times instead of dividing by
this let's multiply by the inverse
what's the universe 15 y to the minus 5
over 8 X to the minus 3 I just flipped
it all right
so let's see what we can do here let's
see if we can look seems like a look we
could a lot of these numbers have common
factors see if we divide 15 by 3 and 27
by 3 so this becomes 5 27 divided by 3
becomes 9 I mean and just so you can
think you could view this as one
continuous denominator right a one
continuous fraction 20 X to the minus 4
times
well now it's 5y to the minus fifth
divided by 9 Y squared type because when
you multiply fractions just multiply the
numerator times the numerator divided by
the denominator times the denominator
anyway let's just keep simplifying if
you divide the this by 2 or 4 you get 5
you know write this by 4 you get 2 let's
see I don't want to do to step too many
steps all at once you get 5 X to the
minus 4 times 5 y to the minus 5th all
of that over 9 Y squared
to X to the minus 3 so let's get all the
numbers out so that is equal to see 5
times 5 is 25 25 over 9 times 2 is 18
times X let's do the X X to the minus 4
right - 4 - because we're dividing - 3
minus minus 3 times y to the minus 5
right y to the minus 5 minus 2 because
we're dividing by that one and that is
equal to 25 over 18 let's see a minus -
so that becomes a plus - 4 + 3 X to the
negative 1 and then minus 5 - 2 y to the
minus 7 and this is the same thing this
is the same thing because this is the
same thing as 1 over X to the 1 is the
same thing as 1 over Y to the 7 so this
is equal to 25 over 18x right 1 over X Y
to the 7th alright Y to the 7th and
denominator same thing as Y to the minus
7 in the numerator and anyway that is
choice let's see 25 over 18 that is
choice D choice D and I'm out of time
see in the next video